changer les regards sur le handicap la
ville de montigny le bretonneux s'y
attelle depuis 15 ans avec sa semaine
dédiée favoriser notamment l'insertion
professionnelle avec ce troisième forum
andy recrutement organisé avec pôle
emploi et l'organisme cap emploi 78
c'est pas parce qu'on est handicapé
qu'on ne peut pas faire des choses et
pour nous l'objectif depuis 15 ans et de
changer le regard sur le handicap et que
les personnes handicapées soient
intégrés dans la ville et que tout se
passe bien pour elle
neuf entreprises du territoire était
présente pour rencontrer les demandeurs
d'emploi parmi elles cette société basée
à versailles qui recrutent exclusivement
des personnes en situation de handicap
on a la difficulté quelques pages
seulement de rencontrer la population de
personnes en situation de handicap et
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment de rencontrer
sur notre bassin de 78 des personnes qui
pourront travailler sur 78 ou sur l'île
de france donc c'est très important pour
nous d'être présent parmi la centaine de
personnes venue au forum même constat
rencontrer un employeur sur place est
une réelle opportunité dans un contexte
où obtenir un entretien d'embauché
s'apparente à un parcours du combattant
ça facilite le contact on n'a pas à le
dire et c'est beaucoup mieux parce c'est
bon tout de suite qu'on dit travailleur
avec un enfant handicapé ont connu un
handicap et tout de suite ça mais c'est
difficile effectivement de atteindra
jusqu'à la rencontre de l'employeur ou
alors faut parfois avoir des scellés qui
ressemblent à des moutons à cinq pattes
un nouveauté cette année au forum trois
ateliers dont un de sensibilisation sur
le langage des signes animé par
l'association harris est la surdité dans
le monde des entreprises posent
plusieurs questions en premier lieu la
communication
et ensuite comment on peut solutionner
ça en fait
en informant les patrons les chefs
d'entreprise en faisant découvrir le
monde de sourds en fait et permettent de
faire des pompes
entre chaque culture en fait c'est comme
ça que l'entreprise peut avancer c'est
pas impossible tout est possible en fait
l'an passé le taux de chômage chez les
personnes en situation de handicap
atteignait 19 % près du double du
pourcentage global de demandeurs
d'emploi